what elements make up a great story
well i think when you're when you're
writing and you sort of have an idea and
you go wow will this actually make a
great feature film or not
um i usually think about okay are these
three elements part of the idea or could
i find a way to sort of embed these
three elements
and one is that it needs to have a main
character
who wants something really badly
and
the second one is it has to promise lots
of conflict like when we
imagine the story and we imagine what
the character wants and what they're
going to have to do to get it we already
start to kind of imagine all the crazy
obstacles that that person's going to
have to face in order to get what they
want and then we get really interested
right and then third i think a way to
tell if your um
idea will make a great movie is
um does it have human emotions in it
that we can relate to you know even if
you're writing about science fiction or
you're writing a horror movie or
something set way in the past where you
really have no
um immediate connection to the time or
place or characters there have to be
those human feelings and desires and
fears that we can relate to you know so
i always think those are the three
criteria that make a great movie or tv
idea um and obviously if you're writing
a tv show you know the idea has to
promise lots of story you know when
you're writing a feature it's a
contained three-act structure right so
it has it's it's a contained story with
an end
so um you know thinking about that idea
all those elements still have to be at
play and then in addition when you're
writing a tv limited series or a tv
show with multiple seasons you know how
are
all those characters and all those
conflicts going to spool out and promise
lots of conflict to come
yeah
great great three tips
first off
how would we know that the characters
want is really strong enough that it
warrants
us being invested in them right
well
as a story consultant i mean i work with
a lot of screenwriters i work with
professional screenwriters who are
working in the industry and i also work
with beginning people and people who are
kind of in the middle of their
journey toward being a professional
screenwriter
but even with the professional
screenwriters that i work with it's
always the same it's like
every time i read the script it's like
what do they want
and
the writer looks at me like
i have no idea like they've written a
whole script and they're just they still
kind of don't understand
what the main character wants and so
when someone is thinking about their
their main character you know i always
like to break down what they want into
two parts like they have an emotional
need
like to find love or connection or for
revenge or power or whatever and then
there's a specific immediate goal that
they pursue in the story that satisfies
that emotional need
so
if you don't have those two things and
know them pretty clearly
you're probably going to write a lot of
pages that you don't end up having in
your final version of the script because
you know i don't i don't know about you
but i've written full scripts where i
literally have no idea what they want
and this happens this happens this
happens and then i look at the script
and i'm like what is this like what is
this thing why should i be invested in
watching this story
so i think a way to know
if you if your character has enough of
an engine to drive a feature or a
television show it's like they have to
have a very specific emotional need
and then they have a very specific goal
that they're pursuing in the story to
satisfy that need now when they start
the movie or the tv show that immediate
goal that they're pursuing could be like
the wrong thing
right
and their goal changes
but usually the emotional need stays
constant as they sort of grow then they
may change that that immediate goal to
kind of
reveal their their growth as a character
or whatever but like you know do you
know
what your character emotionally needs
and wants and then what is it that they
specifically decide to do
to satisfy that need and once you have
that lined up then you're good you're
good to go and start writing
with conflict
how do we know
how much house like is it too much too
soon or there can never be too much
conflict too soon like you know some
people think they have conflict in their
story and it's actually not it's it's
too it's too meek it's not it's not
enough right that's a great question
about conflict um
for me
like even if you're writing the most
small specific character-driven
movie that takes place in a very kind of
um
small location with just a few
characters
there has to be
lots of conflict there needs to be
internal conflict and external conflict
of some kind however that doesn't mean
your your movie has to start with like
conflict conflict conflict conflict too
much conflict because
after a while it's like whoa what is
this what's happening here what's this
about so um one way
to sort of um think about conflict and
how it works especially when you're when
you're writing a feature film is that
you know at the beginning of the story
your character may want something
that they don't have
right and they're just kind of living
their life but we get the sense that
they want something that they don't have
and then there is this inciting incident
or call to adventure where
maybe they have the chance
to get what they want but it's like
super scary right like there's something
emotionally dangerous about that call or
physically dangerous and so they go nope
i'm going to refuse that call because
i'm too afraid and then something
usually happens to kind of force the
person
to take action and heed the call to
adventure and go on the journey at the
end of act one so it's not like you have
to have conflict conflict you know it's
like like
usually most really great stories um
depending on what genre you're writing
in i mean if you're writing an action
movie there should be something big up
top right and then it creates a question
we're like what happened and then we
slow down and we start to go meet up
with the character and what they're
trying to figure out
um so you can have sections of your
script that are quiet where we're just
kind of revealing character and they're
still trying to get what they want but
the conflicts are smaller and more
internal
um
but in the climax of your movie whether
you're writing a tiny movie or you're
writing a huge movie you know where
there's car chases and explosions or
whatever
that is the moment where there has to be
big conflict either emotionally or
physically
so conflict is something
that um you have to kind of modulate
throughout the script right and um there
are moments in the story that are
quieter where maybe we get in act two we
have a moment where everything kind of
slows down and we have a scene with two
characters connecting on a deeper
emotional level that then create bigger
stakes so that when they move into the
next section of conflict the stakes are
even higher just because we had this
really
tiny quiet little scene that had no
conflict in it
so each scene has to move the story
forward and conflict will kind of ebb
and flow
but there always has to be tension in
the story and
um
the reason for that is that you know
every every movie every tv show every
story creates a dramatic question
you know and the dramatic question is
will the person get what they want or
not and that's what holds us to the
story and so if somebody has a goal and
they go after it
and they get it
we're like
okay the story's over like you know um
but if they want something
and it's really hard either emotionally
or physically
we're gonna keep watching because if we
are if we have empathy toward that
character and we understand what they
want and why
we generally want them to get it and so
we're with them and that question of
will they get it or will they not get it
is what holds us to the story and in
order for us for that question to kind
of be
dramatic and suspenseful we need
conflict
yeah
and so what if the character gets what
they want early in the film
but it turns out that
didn't really fulfill their desired need
and we as the viewer go on this journey
to see them get it and we want to root
for them and think oh wow they have it
but then it turns out to be either a
disappointment or um you know traumatic
to their lives and so then
we follow the rest of the film of them
trying to sort out
this this goal
right so
so yeah
like that that happens a lot in
storytelling right where the character
remember when i was talking about that
idea that they that they have this
emotional need and then they have the
specific goal and they pursue the wrong
goal like for example let's just take um
a rom a teen rom-com just because that's
an easy genre to talk about so
so
a trope in rom-coms especially in the
teen sort of world is that
that let's say we have a female
character and she loves the wrong boy
she loves kevin
kevin is the popular boy kevin has the
swoopy hair kevin has the letterman's
jacket right
and um she wants kevin so bad and we the
audience are going
actually
it's joe the nerdy guy that's for you
but but she has to figure it out herself
so let's say she gets together with
kevin
and and she's with kevin and
she's starting to realize like oh
this isn't really good like i don't
really like like him or i don't really
like being part of this
this this crowd or whatever you know
she's starting to realize who she really
loves
which is joe but like she rejected joe
way back there
so now joe is with sally
and now
she has to try to get joe back like it
becomes it because it can become part of
you creating an arc for your main
character and they sort of get a deeper
understanding of what it is they really
want
you know that's related to their
emotional need for love and connection i
don't know if that answered your
question yeah it does it does and i'm
sorry the third part was are there
enough emotions do we feel empathetic
toward the character yeah okay so so
do we so creating empathy i mean for
those of your um your viewers who are
writing you know we all know that the
one thing we really need to create
between the audience and the main
character is empathy and empathy um
to me empathy is sharing the feelings
and understanding why someone's doing
something and recognizing those motives
as human
in yourself
so even if you have an antagonist who's
like doing despicable disgusting
horrible things if we know why that
person is doing it they feel like a real
person
right and they're humanized and they
don't feel stereotypical or villainy you
know like twirling their mustaches
um and with a main character empathy is
is really important too because
again if we're sharing the emotions of
our main character main character in the
story they're actually the window
through which we're experiencing the
journey
so you know the the function of the hero
in storytelling is for the reader or the
audience to actually be in that person
situation and experience that journey
through their eyes and so in order to do
that we have to feel a connection
to that person
so um a lot of times you know students
or writers ask me like i want to write
an anti-hero like my my main character
is not likeable i don't care they're not
gonna be likable and i'm like great
they don't have to be likable but they
do have to be empathetic in other words
we have to understand their motives why
they're doing what they're doing
and so most main characters are likeable
you know like we we like them and we
want them to get what they want but
there are some main characters um
like in the talented mr ripley i don't
know if you've seen that movie but um
tom ripley is does terrible things and i
don't want to do spoiler i think
everybody needs to watch this movie it's
one of my favorite movies especially if
you want to have a main character who
who does bad things but we're still
connected to him and we're still
watching him going
don't do it tom you know it's just like
don't but we know what he wants because
it's set up so clearly at the beginning
that we feel for him and we understand
him and we are riveted by his journey
because as he does one terrible thing
after another we keep wanting him to
have a chance to take it all back and to
make the right choice and so even though
he's an anti-hero we're like please
don't do anything bad please make choose
the person who loves you
he didn't choose you know it's just it's
a brilliant movie because we
we hate the guy but we have complete
empathy
for that person and you know if we're
connected to the character that way we
will follow that person to the end of
the movie or the end of the tv show
because
we're interested we we and we care and
we understand why they're doing what
they do
pat at what point does empathy have to
be present in the story so if we have a
character that's unlikable but
eventually we determine okay we
understand why they're doing what
they're doing
is there a certain point where
the empathy meter has to kick in for the
audience
yeah i actually think the empathy meter
has to kick in on page one
like that connection needs to be
established immediately in the story um
and if it's not
we're gonna struggle to connect to that
person and follow them especially if
they're kind of an anti-hero
main character
so for example in
in the talented mr ripley where tom
ripley is an anti-hero
the the filmmaker and the writer um i
think it's anthony mangala works really
hard on page one to establish why
he wants what he wants
he wants to be seen by people in power
he wants to play music
and he's basically living in poverty and
we see him in this environment and we
see him yearning to be part of this
glittery rich crowd
and so because we are so connected to
him around that because all of us have
been wanting to be part of something
that maybe we can never be part of right
we can all relate to that and so later
when he starts doing terrible things
to stay part of that group that that
glittery crowd
we totally understand why he's doing it
and it's so deeply embedded in our
understanding of the character that he
can pretty much do anything and we will
still follow him through this story so
no matter what kind of movie you're
writing even if it's an anti-hero type
of movie
you have to establish that connection or
that understanding pretty quickly
in the story
what is the mystery that sometimes makes
writing seem so daunting
if only i knew what the mystery was
there's so many mysteries um
okay so
the way i look at writing is like
there's the craft
right there's the things that you can
learn you know like how to create a
great character like what's the react
structure
um how to write a great scene you know
what's good dialogue how to tell a
visual story all that kind of stuff you
can kind of learn that stuff right and
you can you can sort of absorb it and
practice it and get better at it
but the second half of writing is this
weird alchemy and i love that you
described it as magical because it is
magic it feels like magic sometimes
and um
sometimes you can't control that magical
side like this other side that's like i
made an outline and i have my act breaks
and here's the midpoint like that you
can control on the page
but the part of writing
that uses the right side of your brain
that is really holistic and intuitive
and connecting
it's it feels like magic because at
times when at least when i'm writing i
feel like i'm literally just taking
dictation from someone that i'm just
typing these people are talking to me
and i'm writing down what they what they
say
and there are other times where i'm
writing scenes where it's like
enter scene she wants this she does this
to get it there is so it's very kind of
like practical you know
um and i think it's this magical what we
call the magical side of writing that
makes it feel really really daunting and
something that we cannot control
and that you know we want to be able to
go every time i sit down to write it's
magical you know and it's not
and the one thing that i've discovered
about the magical side of writing is
that
it won't happen unless you're sitting in
the chair
you know and and
it's not there the whole time
you know and
it does seem daunting because you can't
control it but if you put in the work if
you sit in the chair if you show up
every day
and create that time
you know for me like if i work at the
same time every day
that becomes magic because
i have created a ritual where i sit down
i turn on my computer i have my coffee
you know
i post a writing quote every morning so
i look and i find a writing quote that
applies to me what am i struggling with
today and then i find that quote and
then i post it and then i sit down and i
start to write
and because i've created these routines
around my writing
the magic is attracted to it
and so it doesn't always go well i mean
you know i have days where i write
nothing or i write one page and it's
really bad
and i know it's bad but i found that
this idea that it's daunting
can actually take on its own dark power
you know that there's this thing out
there and it's magic
and i don't have access to it because
writing for me is hard it's hard for
everyone
you know it's hard how many drafts have
you written of this thing you still have
to try to find that that that thing that
once it clicks it's like oh i found it
you know but in order to attach to that
magic you have to actually be sitting in
your chair and just showing up every
single day
um so and i love that you mentioned
mentioned um richard walter earlier um
in our comments because he was my
screenwriting teacher but he used to he
used to say this this thing in class
which i thought was really great
which is um there's no such thing as
writer's block
that is something that we actually
create in our minds as a way of avoiding
facing things in our writing or in our
script if we're writing about something
that's really emotionally close to us
you know it's like suddenly writing
becomes really hard and now i'm worried
about the person i'm writing about and
they're going to read the script and i
need to change the character and you
know
i think as writers
we have to stop thinking about it as
writer's block
because
we create the block we create the block
because of other things that are going
on and so
you know all we have to do
and all we really can do is show up
in the chair and write and again this is
just my experience i'm sure other
writers have had different experiences
the magic does not come very often at
all but when it comes it's like amazing
and suddenly
things start to make sense and you
didn't understand what the script was
about and why is this character doing
this thing suddenly you go
oh my god this is why she's doing it and
this is what she would do next because
she wants you know and so that that that
connective side of your of your brain is
the magic i think and in order to let it
do its job you just have to
drag your left side of your brain that
made the outline into the chair
and work diligently and ho and just wait
for it to come
you know
so thunder's not going to crash
outside your window while you're i mean
not every time once okay i actually find
thunder crashes inside me
like my anxiety is its own daunting
thing to deal with around writing you
know and if i could if i could tame my
anxiety and really get it under control
i feel like the dauntingness of writing
would be far lessened for me you know
and i don't know i'm sure other writers
struggle with anxiety as well but
it's super it can be very it can take
over your brain
and then you start thinking about other
things and stuff and so
again creating those rituals where you
sit down at your desk and you have your
cup of coffee or your tea or whatever
and you have little colored pencils like
that you really make it almost religious
you know because what happens is when
you you create those patterns the minute
you sit down your brain starts to go
into that mode of like now it's writing
time now i'm going to write you know
so
yeah i don't think you can depend on
inspiration or
like a thunderstorm to inspire you or
whatever um you just have to be diligent
and show up um and and do the work
you know it's great because i i have
this quote here that we were saving for
the end but it it's funny that i chose
this um i saw on your blog that you
loved joan didion yeah and that you were
watching a documentary i think she's had
at least one or two yeah
and um so she says here don't excuse me
do not whine do not complain work harder
spend more time alone and this is from
her 2011 memoir blue nights yes so yeah
i don't know that's that's kind of
fitting it sounds like it that's weird
that i just that's the truth that is the
truth in that one sentence you know as
writers and um especially as women you
know um like
it's hard to find time alone and it's
hard to prioritize your writing you know
especially if you're still working in a
regular job and you're trying to sort of
um your writing but it's
you have kids or family or whatever you
know it's very hard to prioritize that
alone time
but if you don't do it
you won't get the work done
you know and so
um i love what she says about
work hard
carve that space out in your life to be
alone because in order to get your pages
done you really do have to be alone and
you do you know whether you like music
playing or whatever environment you like
to write in you have to act like it's
really important and you have to
prioritize it because if you don't it'll
be the first thing to get shoved away
you know when my when my kids i mean
they're young adults now i have two boys
but when they were babies i used to just
set my coffee pot to like four a.m
would set my coffee pot i would set my
alarm
i would get up at 4 a.m it was
completely quiet everybody was asleep i
would go into the kitchen i would get my
cup of coffee and i would just go into
the den and i would write until six and
then everyone started screaming and
crying and needing me and then i could
start my day and i could do meetings or
whatever i had to do but i had
carved out that
time in the darkness by myself with a
single lamp on with my computer to get
my work done now i was wiped out by 4
p.m like i was like a liv like a zombie
walking through my life but i kind of
arranged my day so that i didn't really
need to do anything
that required a lot of thought at the
end of the day you know so it worked out
for me um but at first it was really
hard to make that commitment and go i'm
getting up at four in the morning
because it was just like
these kids are killing me oh my god you
know it's just
motherhood was like a big a big thing
and um
i just found when i when i had those two
hours in the morning got my work done i
was so much happier the rest of the day
i interacted with my children in a
positive way
and most importantly i got i got my
pages done
you know um
and so how do you carve out that alone
alone time do you need to actually get
out of your house you know sometimes
your house is so busy that there's no
way to work there so is there a coffee
shop that you love where you can go and
just sit there with your latte
and you know stay there for an hour and
a half um one thing that i that i've
read about which is really interesting
and hopefully helpful for the people who
are your viewers is that
they've done studies where people who
write at the same time every day
and create this pattern this habit are
much more productive and tend to finish
their projects
my maya angelou used to um she couldn't
work in her house so she would like she
had a room reserved at a hotel and like
she would show up there at 9am in her
little hotel room she would write until
noon
get her pages done and then in the
afternoon she'd go to lunch
do whatever she
you know if she had meetings or whatever
she needed to do or read you know
whatever she needed to do in the
afternoons she could do but she her she
went to her office
like in this hotel room and created that
ritual for herself away from her family
so that she could get her work done
what about the stigma of well you're
being selfish because people need you
my friend meg lafove talks about lava
all the time which i think is so great
because it's it's that emotional stuff
that triggers you and that stops you and
you know when you're writing about it in
your story it's like it's alive for you
maybe not even in a positive way because
it's so triggering or whatever
um
does do people say it's selfish for
people to go to the bank and work as a
teller
do people say it's selfish to um hello
kitty sorry now i'm feeling she usually
is quiet so she's just like
i know i think she's saying mama i love
it
what about the idea that it's selfish to
set time for oneself for something like
writing when people might need you
well people are always going to need you
and i think the thing that we all have
to struggle with as writers is finding
that time for ourselves and like i said
really prioritizing it and believing in
ourselves that it is important and so i
always wonder like you know does anyone
say like the guy who goes to work at the
bank is like selfish because he's like
doing his job you know or somebody who
works in a supermarket who's the cashier
you know are they selfish
they're they're doing their job and if
you are a writer and whether you're
earning money as a writer or not if
you're writing you're a writer and so
that's your job and so if you have to
fit it in around you know actually
earning a living that's great but i
don't know if any of your viewers have
had this experience but like when i
don't write
i don't feel good
i get mad i feel testy i'm like upset
you know like i
i just feel like i'm not myself and i
get very like angry and i start to hold
on to things because i'm actually not
honoring who i am
and expressing myself in the way that i
was meant to you know so instead of
looking at setting aside time to write
as being kind of a selfish thing
you know it's a thing that's actually
necessary to you as a human being to
actualize and be who you are meant to be
and so it's important
it's as important as anything and if you
give yourself that time to honor who you
are and that you love to write and that
writing gives you joy
and allows you to express yourself
everything else in your life will be
better because of it and so
anyone who says you're selfish
i think you need to think about
how that's about them
and not about you and what you're doing
you know
why are they trying to stop you from
doing the thing that you love
excellent yeah
and lastly
again what are some of the items as part
of the ritual so you said you have a cup
of coffee or tea
you sit down at a certain time and you
have these colored pencils common
colored pencils i've got my little um
like i'm a left brainer so like
everything is organized kind of like i
that's who i am as a person so um
yeah i i get my my coffee is key
back when i was in film school i used to
smoke cigarettes and so i finally was
like oh my god i gotta quit cigarettes
they're really bad i was having a cough
and everything so i'm like okay i'm
gonna stop smoking so i stopped smoking
i got the patch i could not write
because the smoking was so connected to
my ability to be able to like think and
be creative i had created this
connection that i had to actually sever
that connection it was really hard but
now coffee is my vice so i have my cup
of coffee i have my mug i sit down at my
computer i use pencils i love pencils
they wear down you can erase things you
can
they disappear you know like as you sort
of sharpen them and keep writing they
disappear which is kind of proof of of
all the stuff that's come out of my
pencil i can like see it because now
it's a nub you know um
i have colored pencils to
underline certain things with certain
characters in my outline so that i can
track who you know how their arc is
building in my outline
and it's just a way of me a way of me
organizing my writing time
that that
it's so ritualized
that i don't have to think about what's
next it's like that part of the
practical part of writing is just like
i'm in the scene i'm writing i've got
the coffee which makes my brain feel
like it's writing time it's writing time
here comes the caffeine you know and um
i don't know just these rituals really
help me i do not listen to music when
i'm writing i i cannot because it's
distracting to me i can i can listen to
music if it doesn't have lyrics if there
are words i start listening to the
lyrics which is problematic for me my
husband's a screenwriter and he creates
a soundtrack for whatever he's writing
and he's got it
blasting in his ears and like he's like
and i'm just like oh my god could you be
quiet
my process is different than yours um
but and he you know when he when he
writes dialogue he's just he's saying
the words out loud and so he has this
very kind of like
um extroverted version of his process
but mine is really quiet and just kind
of like focused with my coffee and
my silence you know um
and um i get up every hour i walk around
which helps me you know if i sit for too
long i start to actually ruin the stuff
that i wrote so i find getting up and
moving my body is really helpful but
yeah i've just created these rituals
that you know signal to my brain
it's time to work you know and that's
been really helpful
you know what's interesting about the
cigarette and not i mean i wasn't a huge
smoker but there and cancer is not sexy
and emphysema is not sexy but there is a
there's a very sensual way
that one can think with a cigarette oh
yeah that's whether it's parisian or
whatever i mean there's a way to exhale
and each one means different things so i
could see how that would be a difficult
thing aside from the nicotine well and i
didn't realize that i had been smoking
so much when i was writing and working
but it had that connection had been made
and just the breathing in and the
breathing out and the nicotine which
then i substituted with caffeine i think
there's definitely a stimulant
effect that i like when i'm working
but boy was i
was i shocked when i realized like i
can't think anymore without smoking
and i have to find something else to
kind of substitute
in for that yeah and it's also too the
way you ash some you know there's just
little effects fingers right like
it blows and you're you're just like in
this cocoon of fog which i loved you
know yeah um yeah and all my clothes
smelled like smoke i thought i think at
that time i thought it was very romantic
it's probably disgusting
but yeah well you know there was a time
and a place for some of that and it was
also you know you could commiserate with
other smokers it was a very social thing
but i could see how with writing and you
know also having an alcoholic beverage
like certain things would play into that
writer persona that's right that would
be hard to break but that's right i
could never write with alcohol it's just
i'm such a lightweight it just doesn't
work for me but things that are
stimulate stimulants like cigarettes and
coffee have always been kind of like my
my bad friends
my friends that i know i shouldn't be
hanging out with right right that your
mother warned you about she did but they
were so much fun they were so much fun
yeah
how do you help writers find the
emotional spine of their story yeah oh
that's a great question
so the emotional spine is the most
important thing
it is the most important thing and
oftentimes it's
one of the last things that becomes
really clear because sometimes you have
to write through a bunch of stuff to
actually realize what the emotional
spine is of your story
but one way that i work with writers on
finding their emotional spine of their
story is
by using the hero's journey and the
reason i actually like that story model
is i think it's the deepest kind of
psychological model and it really is
about fear
and facing
whatever darkness we have in ourselves
you know in pursuing what we want
and so
what i do
with writers when they're you know
sometimes writers have a really great
story but i'm like what do they want
what's the emotional growth like what's
their flaw what's their problem
we actually do kind of um talk through
this idea of the hero's journey
and often what's missing is um
like a fear like some people write main
characters that are like perfect like
they're just good people and they always
do the right thing and it's like after a
while it's kind of like wow the
secondary characters are really fun and
interesting and your main character is
just kind of like dull
you know and so how do you
take some of that juice that you've
given your secondary characters and
really create a main character who's
complicated and flawed you know and it's
so good to have a character that has a
flaw because
then they make mistakes which creates
more conflict and then they do things
out of fear which allows us to
understand them more deeply you know and
create structure so which creates
structure for us so so what i do is we
sort of talk through okay
what is your character afraid of
like what is their emotional need let's
say it's love and connection and let's
just say they're afraid of being
rejected just to pick them a really
simple example
right and so
i encourage writers to think about why
are they afraid of being rejected like
what happened to them
what happened to them and to actually
write that scene even if it's not going
to be in the movie like what is the
scene
where they were rejected in some really
primal deep way
then
they are grounded in that character's
backstory and they don't have to do a
flashback
but everything they write is going to be
infused with that thing that happened to
them
and it's going to infuse the way that
they interact with the world and how
their fear gets triggered right
and so
a great character let's say let's say
they got rejected in their past
and they're going along in their life
and they want love but they don't have
it
and the call to adventure is
oh my god that person
that's my person
but they refuse the call because they're
too afraid of being rejected right again
so we're getting internal conflict
and then
maybe i can do it this time maybe i can
actually put myself out there so they
talk to their friends or they get some
guidance from somebody you know and like
in the meeting the mentor section of the
hero's journey
and they they realize like if i do if i
if i do this then maybe i'll i'll be
able to be with that person and so they
decide to go for it and they commit to
like
i'm gonna i'm gonna make that person
love me
you know and they set off on their quest
and now we're in act two and they go for
their goal and there's people who are
helping them like yeah yeah he really is
really into you let's do this you know
and someone people are trying to stop
stop her i'm just gonna say it's a she
at this point you know like
you're not his type
he likes this other girl like putting
that fear so that that fear is
externalized through a character that
can press on that character in the story
and but they really want that person so
bad and so they keep moving forward and
the middle of act two in the hero's
journey is called approach to the inmost
cave
and the way to think about your story in
this section is that in the cave is the
treasure which is that person that she
wants
to fall in love with her
right and she really wants that person
really badly
but the cave is made up of her fear
because she wants him she's she's going
to go for him but as she's going for him
she gets more and more vulnerable
and so her emotions get triggered
and she's afraid and maybe you know a
lot of times in a romantic comedy or a
romance story you know the midpoint in
act 2 is a kiss or some kind of intimate
connection
and that triggers let's just say for our
character that we just made up right now
that triggers her fear like oh my god
i'm
so she pushes away again to protect
herself and the other person's like wait
what's going on i thought we and she's
you know and then she she does something
even more sort of out of her fear
and now she's at the end of act two
she's completely alone she's blown it
and she's failed and that person is with
someone else
and she's never ever gonna have that
person
love her
okay
but then
maybe the mentor comes in or maybe she
discovers something
that allows her to believe she has a
chance one more chance and so she
decides
i'm gonna i'm gonna try to get him one
more time and that launches her into act
three and then there's that race you
know or she's trying to get to the
person whatever
and in that scene
she has to face
her fear like like you know the classic
cliche version of this is like she's
running to the airport oh my god he's
leaving on a play she gets there and
there goes the plane
he's gone
right so that s that death of her dream
at the end of act two where she failed
is reenacted once more
and it's like oh my god she's not going
to get what she wants
but then she turns and there he is he
didn't get on the plane or
he goes on the plane and he leaves
and in a scene that happens after that
they meet again by accident or something
and she tells him
how she feels and she opens herself up
and she's completely vulnerable which is
her growth and her transformation and
because she's grown and because she's
revealed
her true feelings
he's like hell yeah i'll be with you and
she gets what she wants
so the hero's journey by creating this
idea of the fear in in the character and
actually grounding it in a real thing
that's something you can play with in
the story to create emotional growth for
the main character
and another way that i like to think
about um
creating emotional structure
for the for the character in the story
is that you know
how are they going to change
and um this may be a richard walter
thing again i don't know if i'm pulling
this from richard i probably am but he i
think in his book he talks about
this idea of um like a bow and arrow
and if you're let's just say you know at
the end of this movie that you're
writing that she's gonna stand before
him
and say how much she loves him and be
really vulnerable
so that's the that's where the arrow
lands right so in creating the arc the
emotional arc you want to pull that that
arrow back as far away from that as you
can
so that
there it looks like there's no way she
can ever be vulnerable with anybody okay
so that you're you're creating these
this polarity in the story of how who
she is at the beginning what her belief
system is about herself
and the world and then how it changes at
the end and then you're kind of building
the emotional journey between those two
poles so that's another way to think
about creating emotional structure
you know as you were speaking i it was
taking me back to 16 candles oh my god
so i mean i i realize i'm going back a
few years but i'm so i'm thinking of the
molly ringwald character yes and she's
feeling left out because her sister's
wedding right yeah and and everybody's
busy yes and then
she has the crush on jake jake right
yeah you all remember jake and he's got
like sort of the cheerleader girlfriend
and in her mind
he's totally unattainable but he was
perfect right and so she's at the dance
and then she gets sort of this unwanted
attention but it's part mentor right the
the one forgive me it was anthony
michael hall yes okay yeah and and he
was awesome in the film and and he's
kind of a mentor but he's also trying to
pick her up yeah and and so you know and
then yeah we don't want to spoil it even
though the movie is 30 years
okay all right it's it's been it's been
lit but it's so then there's the moment
where there he is yes and
it's the awkward and i forget he's got
his car he probably has like this or
whatever yeah yeah and so and then they
have the weird conversation and
you know yeah yeah so i'm thinking of
i'm thinking of that that's exactly how
yeah the all is lost right at the end of
act two we have it where you know the
the person is with someone else and then
the character has to kind of relive it
in the climax again
right
um and um that character of jake it's so
interesting because i i watched that
movie a few months ago his character is
so problematic
oh is he oh yeah i mean it's but it's
fascinating to watch it from 2021
back and and going oh yeah we thought
that was okay or whatever you know a lot
of the stuff that happens in that movie
but that's exactly what i'm talking
about that emotional structure of like
there he is
you know and um
yeah and sometimes the way that that
emotional growth happens in the climax
is also
you know like the the hero is sort of in
the climax it looks like they're they're
they're not going to get what they want
again you know that person's gone or
whatever
but because of what they've learned on
the journey they do something
emotionally they never could have done
at the beginning of the movie and
because they do it in that moment
they actually get what they want and
they might not get it in the want in the
way that they wanted or thought they
would get it back then but it's it could
be in a new way that is actually even
better than the way they thought they
were gonna get it
how does a writer find the central
thematic spark of their screenplay the
central thematic spark oh yeah
that's like the magic that's part of the
magic that we were talking about i think
um
for me and this is just my experience is
theme comes like almost last
like i
it's not it's not a spark in the sense
of like a catalyst for an idea for me it
really is something that comes after
i've kind of
worked a lot and and basically thought
oh that's the theme and then no that's
not the theme and then that's the theme
and that's not the theme and suddenly
the theme is the thing for me that comes
last it comes for me as a writer when i
have figured out who the characters are
what they want deeply what their fears
are
and as i see them
struggling to kind of get what they want
and
again it really happens for me toward
the end of the writing process in
revision
because i may think i have a theme
starting out and it's never that never
ends up what it's about because as i
explore and excavate my characters it it
it appears and it does feel like magic
because for me it's about like oh my god
this movie's really about this
i had no idea that it was about this and
i work with a lot of writers too who
think they know what their theme is
and um
it turns out that what they're writing
is not what they started out thinking
their movie was about and it's evolved
into something else and so that those
little things that they thought were
really important at the beginning of the
writing process end up falling away
in favor of whatever is now sort of
taking hold because of the character
development
in in the story
um so for me it's really it's part of
the magic and i don't i don't really
even know what my movie's about when i
when i start
anymore i just i trust that i will know
and i don't i don't know i have i have
found when i was first starting out
writing that when i started with a theme
like this is a movie about blank
that
it kind of became wooden
you know because i was basically just
writing to fulfill some prescriptive
kind of
tenet or something i don't know but when
i just
trust that i don't need to know my theme
i'll wait for it it will come to me
usually it does
sometimes it doesn't and i have to have
other people read it to tell me what do
you think this is about because i just
kind of get lost in the weeds
um
yeah arthur miller i love this the way
he that we the way he worked with theme
um he had this little building outside
of his house that was like his writing
shed i'm sure it was really beautiful so
calling it a shed is probably wrong but
he would go out there and he obviously
was working on a typewriter right
because it was the 50s or whatever and
he would he would start writing his
plays and
he said that in the writing process he
would suddenly realize what the theme
was
and it was usually when he was kind of
in the middle of writing his play and
then he would type up the theme and put
it above the typewriter and that guided
the rest of his writing
so he would find his theme in the middle
of the process of writing his plays
um and i'm sure there are some people
who have a theme at the beginning and
are able to kind of write to that
but it it to me it's kind of like
it's magical like it's it's you need to
like leave it you need to let it come to
you um because i think it's not
even though a theme feels intellectual
like this movie is about this
i think theme theme is actually really
like from the heart it's a heart thing
not like a brain thing
um interesting yeah
so it sounds like okay because so much
of writing seems like there's these
rules and you're connecting the dots to
so much but with this
and i'm sure this is hard for writers to
do you're letting it go and you don't
know that's right that sounds like it's
very troublesome for writers so
troublesome i mean and and and obviously
i'm not i'm not saying like go crazy
just write everything because it's a
balance like as a human being you have a
left brain you have a right brain
organizer holistic intuitive you need
both of them to write a great script
okay and so you know part of it is
magical
but but part of it is actually figuring
out like creating a map for yourself so
that you don't go out into the weeds now
i know people i know a lot of people who
don't have outlines that's great like if
you can do that if you can figure it out
and really let yourself be completely
free which to me is terrifying
i cannot be completely free because i
will just shut down it's too scary so i
make a road map for myself um but then
if i'm in there and it's like oh this
isn't working the way i thought it would
and this is boring like where should
this where should this be going
you know and try to follow those things
so it's a balance of
of structure and also allowing for
creative discovery in the writing
process
you know so set your your sort of time
your date with yourself to sit down
whether it's longhand or at the
typewriter have your little rituals your
offerings have your offerings and then
start writing yeah and then
hopefully the thunder outside the window
brings what the theme is about or like
you said you you had other people look
at your work and say what they thought
the theme was yeah i mean when i get
really stuck and basically people come
to me when they're stuck right like
they've looked at their script and they
have taken it as far as they can
and they just need someone from the
outside to look at it we all do you know
and so i have people who look at my
stuff i have a friend um it's a it's a
girls group and
it's writers it's producers
it's teachers it's storytellers and you
know we're friends it's a social group
but we also share
our materials with each other if we need
feedback and it has been so helpful i
just um i just wrote a book and i just
felt like i i don't know what to do with
this anymore and i gave it to them and
they were brutal
and they're extremely smart and i was
just like
oh my god
this is gold and i was able to go back
in there see what i couldn't see right
because they're coming and so i think we
all as writers need
those people like who's our little
circle
of um
who's our community of fellow writers
that we can go to and i'll read your
stuff and you read my stuff because yes
writing is a lonely sport but you can't
always be alone you actually do need
people
you know and that's the great thing
about working on a tv show because
you're in a room with lots of people now
there are issues that come out of that
right like personalities and all that
stuff and i'm sure you've talked to
people who are tv writers who have
stories to tell about writing rooms but
like the great thing about it is you're
in a room with other people
and you know i've worked as a story
consultant at pixar and one of the
things i absolutely loved is that like
i'm in a room with other people and
we're working together on this story
which is not normally the way feature
writers work
which is i'm a feature writer so it's it
was it was so fun to me to for for me to
be in a room with other people um and so
you know i want to advise people like
find your group like who are your people
who can you share this experience with
and give encouragement to and notes to
and all that kind of stuff because
you can only take your project so far
alone you need other people
yeah and so with the talented mr ripley
what is the theme
gosh
the talented mr ripley is based on a
book by patricia highsmith
and patricia highsmith is one of my
favorite writers she's extremely dark
and it's all about twisted human
psychology
um and she wrote the price of salt which
be which um actually phyllis naj turned
into the
amazing movie carol right so she wrote
about not just super dark things but but
other other things as well but um the
talented mr ripley honestly i don't know
what the theme is
it it it it
it doesn't i think the thing i love
about the movie and the book is that it
won't fit into our prescribed little
boxes of theme
you know or meaning because the main
character is this guy who's doing
everything a main character should never
do
and yet we're riveted by him
and so
we're able to kind of see
the humanity in the darkness in the dark
psychology and so i think
what i'm attracted to in her is that and
for me that's the theme it's like wow
monsters are human too
and they are just like me in some ways
so that's why i love her stuff
and her writing you know it's
it's so unique and so specific that you
you you can try
to kind of like box her in to like what
we understand as like this kind of movie
or this kind of book or this kind of
thing but like
she will not be boxed
which is what makes her great but she
faced a lot of criticism especially at
that time absolutely and you know her
politics were terrible i mean she really
was was in many ways not a great human
being
but as a writer like i have to admire
how
she just did what everyone said don't do
it don't do it and yet
and in doing that created these really
compelling characters that we should buy
all rights
not like and not feel empathy toward and
i think she pulls it off i'm not talking
about carol i'm talking about ripley
which is a completely different
character
um but yeah she just breaks the rules
which i love
yeah why do you teach your students
three different types of story
structures so you have the hero's
journey the three-act structure and then
something that was new to me which is
the jewel syllables
11-step model
yeah so
you know there are all these different
story structure models out there in the
world and you know they just have
different terms but they're all
basically kind of the same approach to
story structure
um
so and every writer has a different
process and a way of thinking about
stories so i think it's really good to
expose yourself as a writer to all the
different models and see okay which one
helps me you know and i think the
important thing to remember is it's
their forms not formulas it's not
something you should follow like paint
by number like here's page 30 this is
where the turning point mid six midpoint
is on page 60 you know like like i
really use these um story models as
inspiration rather than you know some
sort of set of rules that i have to
follow um and so i like to give my
writers different tools to put in their
toolbox and then to use the ones that
are helpful to them and there are um
there are three that i really like and
there's others too that are really
amazing but i just find
it you know i don't want to give people
too many things which just makes them
crazy and confused including myself by
the way so um i like the hero's journey
which we've already talked about and i
use that which is you know the ordinary
world the call to adventure the refusal
to the call out of fear
meeting the mentors crossing the
threshold blah blah
so so for those those people that are
really interested in psychological
storytelling and emotional journeys i
think that's that's the number one one
and you know that story model is
fascinating because joseph campbell who
actually identified that pattern of
storytelling you know he studied myths
and fairy tales across all different
kinds of cultures and across all
recorded history
and it's the same pattern
so
it it and he sort of likens characters
in these myths and fairy tales to those
that carl jung found in our unconscious
brain
and it's like i think the reason this
story model is so powerful
is it comes from our human brain
our need to have a story told in a
certain way where we're processing our
own fears and our own
struggles you know
so i i love that story model it helps me
a lot again not a formula it's a form
you can move those and shift those
phases around you know or draw or not
have a phase you know it's up to you to
use it creatively
and you can see that pattern in
hollywood movies you can also see it in
um
more independent
slightly experimental films you can find
traces of it so it just depends how much
you want to embrace that in your in your
structure um and then i also talk a
little bit about three act structure
which is kind of the way everybody talks
about story structure you know um
ordinary world inciting incident
act one turning point you know um
midpoint end of act two where the
everything falls apart and then i'm
gonna try one more time and then climax
and then resolution
and that's just a really simple way to
think of feature writing which is mostly
what i focus on with writers um
so there's that model
and then there's the jewel sell bow
model and i'm going to get my cheat my
channel oh please yeah yeah this was new
to me but i jules selbo wrote a book i
can't remember the name of it but it's
um it's j u l e s e elbow
s-e-l-b-o and she is wonderful and this
this way of telling future
stories is so simple and so clear and i
just find it really helpful so i'll
share that with you um
and again you know if if you find that
this is like working for you and you
really um are attracted to it like get
her book because it explains it in much
more detail
but she basically says there are 11
steps in a feature film the first step
is the character's overall want and why
so you establish through action what
they want and why they want it
and then the character logically goes
for it so they take action to try to get
that thing that they want
but the character is somehow denied
okay they they that's not gonna work
they can't they can't get it that way
um but the character gets a second
opportunity
to um achieve their overall want
but
there's danger around that second
opportunity like it's kind of a shady
way maybe it's not on the up and up but
there's some danger around it either
emotionally or physically okay
but they want it so badly at the end of
act one
they go for it
they decide to go for it again
these these forms are the same like
they're just different language around
the same turning points and stuff but at
the end of act one the character decides
to go for it and now we're in act two
right and so um
all goes well they're going for it look
they're getting what they want oh my god
but
something happens in the middle of the
script and one thing i would love to
share with your viewers is this idea of
the midpoint you know um sometimes the
midpoint people think of it as like
something happens out of the blue that
that
causes everything to fall apart or it's
like a false victory and then they have
to deal with its false or whatever but i
always think the best mid-points are a
moment where the character just like
everything's going okay they're getting
what they want
but then they get to that cave and it's
like they're in that cave and their fear
is around them and they make a decision
out of fear
that causes everything to fall apart for
them they go back to their old pattern
and that actively gives them
like they drive that midpoint and and
causes everything to fall apart which in
jewels um
um 11-step structures called all falls
apart
right so all falls apart looks like
they're going to fail
and then at the end of act two there's a
crisis where they again have to make a
decision or commitment
um do they go for a new strategy do they
give up
you know what do they do usually they
decide to try again and that decision or
that crisis decision drives them into
act three
um and then we have this climax where
it's the final attempt to get what they
want and again usually we have a
transformation right they do something
they never could have done back in act
one they get what they want and then the
last phase she calls truth the truth
comes out to make things right and this
is where um
that the character discovers something
new about her world
she has some new insight about herself
and that usually has the power to heal
whatever was broken back at the
beginning of the story
and so what i love about this this story
model is that it's really goal driven
you know it's like they want something
they decide to go for it they get
blocked they get a second opportunity
i'm afraid i want it so much i'm going
to go for it it's just it allows you to
really find that goal for your character
and let them pursue that in the story
that's awesome and who was jewel salvo
jules selbo is an incredible writer i
can't say enough great things about her
she's a friend she's
a wonderful woman she's super talented
writer
i met her as just a colleague as a
writer and a person who worked with
screenwriting students
she's written a bunch of different
movies she did a lot of animation
she's um writing novels now she just
wrote a new kind of like detective novel
that just came out
and she's phenomenal and i think she's
still teaching but she really just
looked at all this material out there
and she said i'm going to make up my own
version of this that's really simple
it's really character and goal driven
and i've used that 11 step story
structure a lot in my own work and with
clients
now you have a film that you wrote and
directed that starred alicia silverstone
yes and it's a true crime it's called
true crime okay yes please don't watch
it it's not very good oh no no no i
would love to tell my true crime story
if um people are interested if any if
any of your viewers are interested in
being filmmakers um in addition to being
writers you know like wanting to make
your own films um because i actually
started out and i wanted to be a
director and i went to ucla film school
i was in the directing program there i
got my mfa there and i was um positive
that that's what i wanted to do
until i directed a movie called true
and i just found um
it was it was a great experience like i
learned so much but i also realized i'm
not a director like i don't enjoy being
kind of the focus of everybody's
questions and lots of
stress and all that stuff i really
realized like oh my gosh i had such a
great time writing the script like i'm
the right i'm the writer i'm not the
director
but it was it was a great experience and
what it taught me as a writer
is because because i was directing it
too and it was pretty low budget you
know at the time we had like 18 days to
shoot it so it was kind of crazy
um
what i what i found is and i wish i had
known this before i actually directed it
is how important it is if you're
actually making your own scripts like
you're and you're kind of doing it diy i
mean i had a studio that i think the
budget was 1.2 million dollars which at
the time was it was a decent low budget
movie um but what i wish i had known and
i wish i had listened to people who told
me is you know
make it contained
don't have a lot of different locations
really boil your script down to only the
scenes that you absolutely need to tell
your story because what ended up
happening is that we would have company
moves and
i just i every day i lost scenes where
the producers were just like we can't
shoot that scene because we're not
enough time
and so it was just very frustrating to
to watch my story you know eventually it
kind of makes sense you know in the
editing room we had to kind of rewrite
the movie to to fix all the things that
we couldn't shoot um but and it kind of
worked out but um what was great about
it is i learned i didn't want to be a
director i really learned that i am a
writer through and through i like being
alone yes i like being with other people
in a room too but i do not like being on
a set and being in charge of a bunch of
people
it was just extremely uncomfortable for
me
sure i mean sometimes the idea of
something sounds wonderful and the title
of it and then once you actually get
into doing it then you realize that okay
this isn't for me but is it for me i'm
gonna get through this you know and i
had done it in film school i had
directed several films which i loved
doing but it was on a much smaller scale
it was just
my friends and i making a movie and it
was great but when it became this big
thing i just realized
you know i don't have the temperament to
really um deal with all the stress
sure sure now um what prompted you to
write the story
the um that story oh that was that this
is actually might be really interesting
um for your viewers um i got out of film
school and i you know i said i was in
the directing program so i had a couple
short films that i had made but my agent
said you need to write something you
need to write a feature and i was like
okay um what should i write about i have
no idea and i remembered back to
something that happened to me when i was
a little girl um when i was like 9 or 10
years old i was at my grandparents house
and i was i don't know i was looking for
something and i went to my grandfather's
closet and i found the stack of true
detective magazines which back in the
day were like
you know the way we have true crime now
it's all over television well back in
the day it was kind of this secret thing
there were these magazines right
and um i was like oh what are these
magazines you know i'm like a 10 year
old oh and i opened them up and it's
like literally photos of like dead
bodies with like black strips over their
eyes and i was just like ah what is this
and then i was reading and
they described like how the person got
murdered and how the detectives
you know went after them and figured out
who had committed the crime and
everything and part of me was like this
whole ugly world of like the real world
was opened up to me but i also was like
this is cool like detective stuff like i
like this you know but my grandfather
was like patty and i was like oh put it
away pretend like i never thought
what i'm innocent um but i also you know
it really ignited in me this interest in
true crime which i still have um but as
i was thinking of you know what i want
to write i was like oh maybe i could
write about like that thing of finding
those magazines so i ended up
fictionalizing it and i just made it
about a high school girl who's obsessed
with true crime magazines
and um a girl at her high school gets
murdered and she decides she's gonna
find out who the killer was so it's kind
of like a nancy drew
kind of
you know beast b-level movie about this
girl who wants to find the killer
and it's kind of a coming-of-age story
really um but it came from my own
experience you know and a lot of the
stuff that i write
it it may not be technically literally
what happened to me but there's always
something in there that did happen to me
you know and so i think when you're
looking for a story you always want to
have that personal connection somehow
because that's kind of where the juice
is for you as a writer
you know especially if you're scared to
write it that's a good thing
well the million-dollar question is what
was the theme
oh the theme
i think the theme
ended up being
be careful what you wish for
be careful what you wish for interesting
you know
um you think you know the way the world
works
little girl you have no idea
you know so it's kind of dark it was
kind of a dark theme sure
yeah
when you were writing a story what type
of structure do you use most often
hero's journey
that's that's i use that structure
probably the most because um
again it helps me kind of track the
emotions of my character what are they
afraid of what do they want
how do they have to kind of face that
fear
i'm writing something now
and i decided to do something i should
probably not have done which is like
i'm gonna go free i'm gonna i'm gonna
try to just
start writing this thing and i just i
just barfed it out which is which is
actually good for me because i need to
actually do that because i tend to be
over here in my left brain a lot and so
i i barfed this thing out and it's like
it's like 70 pages i'm not even really
sure what it is except it is a detective
themed thing
um but i read through it again and now
i'm going oh okay
i think this is what it is like this one
little part over here
that's where
like the the juice lies
and so now i'm taking that little juicy
thing and going okay
how can i sort of
approach the rewrite with more of a map
and a view to kind of now what i think
it's about
and so usually i just i i make a very
loose outline um it's not detailed it
really just says kind of like the major
action beats you know like what happens
in the inciting incident or the call to
adventure and whether the person pushes
away from it out of fear and then what
happens next to kind of pull them in
um but i want to leave it kind of not
not detailed because then that leaves
things for me to discover when i'm
writing
so is it harder for you to not be
organized and invested in structure yes
it's very hard for me to be free that's
why i think i gave myself that challenge
of just
pat let
step away from the outline
step away
and i needed to kind of just go blah you
know and um when i did that i actually
found really interesting things
happening that i didn't expect and again
that's where i found that little spark
that was like oh this is this is what
it's about um
so yeah for me and i think writers
should challenge themselves like what's
hard for you
make yourself do that thing
make yourself do it even if you're
scared of doing it you know make
yourself do it and then um get more
comfortable with it because there's
something in there
that's scaring you and that's good
you need to go there you need to go into
your own approach to the cave as a
writer you know um
so i work with a lot of people who are
writing kind of um
memoir
book books i work with authors as well
and a lot of the times they're like i
think i'm going to change this
so that it's not about the person so
that they when they and i'm like you
know what
this is your draft no one's going to
read it but you
write every single thing that happened
write the truth because if you're
holding back
we're going to know
that you're being untruthful with us now
after you get out this version where
everything the truth is everything
everybody did is on the page
then you can go back and modulate and
figure out but you have to tell the
truth you know and
if you're writing a script that is based
on experience and you find yourself
going i don't want to write that scene
you got it you got to go there you know
that's the scene
that's what your movie's about and
you're afraid to go there because like
there's something in there that you just
don't want to look at or you know
yeah
and so for a
right-brained writer
who's messy and chaotic and everything's
sort of based on intuition then what
would scare them is probably structure
rules
numbered sequence you know right and and
i've worked with a lot of right-brained
writers you know and it's always it's
just a matter of usually they don't they
it's not like they do a 180 and suddenly
become
like i'm have detailed outlines usually
it's just getting them to a place
that is comfortable for them
to organize something so that they don't
get lost in the weeds you know their
right brain is their strength it's like
their superpower but it can also lead
them into the darkness and down tangents
and out into the woods and then they
don't know how to get back and oh my god
where's the flashlight so you know
helping them find something that's
comfortable in terms of organization
but not too detailed you know um
and sometimes it's even just a matter of
talking through the character's
emotional journey and how they change
that gives them enough in their head to
kind of guide their writing as their
writing so maybe they don't even write
an outline they just kind of talk it
through
so that they kind of know where they're
going
you know
wouldn't know anything about it yeah is
that your i i'm your right brain yeah
yeah tried and true yeah yeah
check out the hero's journey okay yeah i
love um the interview that uh bill
moyers did with um joseph
it's so excellent and and
he just um the two of them together were
just a great team oh yeah yeah in terms
of uh the interview yeah that's a great
that's a great piece of i'm so glad they
recorded it right for posterity wouldn't
you say that if writers and filmmakers
follow these structures that their films
will be predictable you know that's
often something we get in our comments
yes and well this is why
hollywood produces
you know these formulaic movies yes
yes that's always the danger
that's always the danger and you know
when you're watching a formulaic movie
you know
when you know exactly what's going to
happen in the climax on
10 minutes in
you know that that movie is gonna
fulfill
those expectations right
so
there's a couple of ways to approach
that idea of cliche and predictability
um if you're writing you know the
predictability doesn't just lie along
structure lines it also lies along genre
lines that certain genres hold have
conventions
that become familiar patterns right and
so um the trick is to look at these
forms whether it's a structural form
like the hero's journey or three-act
structure as a form and not a formula
that it's just there to give you some
landmarks to help work through you know
the story with your character
um and then if you're writing in a
specific genre you know if i'm writing a
horror movie
and it doesn't have scary stuff in it
like that's going to be a failure so i
have to understand the genre i'm working
in and what the expectations of my
audience are
and i have to deliver that in a way that
feels fresh the audience is coming to
your movie with expectations of the
conventions of that genre they're going
to want to see
in the romantic comedy the mistaken
identity or the misheard thing or the
kiss at the end or whatever so how do
you deliver those things
without making them feel like boring and
cliched and well well trod right so
that's your challenge as a writer to um
to either embrace the conventions and
make them feel fresh or kind of subvert
them
i just watched a movie last week it's
not a great movie but it's it's good and
it's it's very like lovely um the
mitchells versus the machines on netflix
it's an animated movie um
and one thing they did at the ending
which i thought was really funny is you
know in the hero's journey the way that
they kind of combated this idea of like
and now this is gonna happen and now
this is gonna happen
what happens is you know in the hero's
journey in the climax when you're facing
off against the bad guy it looks like
you're gonna die oh no they died but
then they live
so what they did in the movie um
is um they face the robots you know and
the family's fighting and they they beat
the robots and it's like they destroy
the bad guy and it's like yay
but then the main character has fallen
into this pit
and the family gathers around it's like
oh my god katie no and it looks like
she's dead and she just pops up she goes
just kidding
they're mocking
that story moment
in the pharaoh's journey and so they're
acknowledging it and they're making fun
of it and we laugh and so there's ways
of embracing things at the same time
that you're kind of like going yeah i
know what i'm doing i know that that is
that moment i'm gonna have fun with it
um
so i think um
i think you have to um
i think you have to kind of find your
way
toward um
originality you know um and you know
some people say you know there's
there's movies that don't you know
embody some sort of three-act structure
which is absolutely true
you know there are films that are mini
plot or anti-plot but the thing that
people have to understand is that mini
plot and anti-plot are a response to
arch plot which is three-act structure
they are responses to the classical form
okay so they take elements of three-act
structure and twist them and use them in
different ways so like in a mini plot
movie you might get all the information
you might get all this information
except what you're used to getting in a
normal movie so they're messing with
your expectations of information that
you get about the character or
the main character in the mini plot play
or the anti-plot play or movie
may not change right but the audience
has a shift has a transformation so
they're taking these elements and
turning them around you know and using
them in different ways but in order to
do that successfully you have to
actually understand arch plot
so for those of you who are interested
in like
doing really cool weird things with
structure like just learn what classical
structure is
and then you know think about how you're
subverting it or playing with it or
commenting on it because
that's where really interesting stuff
starts to happen structurally
in dramatic storytelling
can you think of a movie that does that
that
yeah well tarantino does that all the
time you know like he plays around with
these conventions
of you know ways that we're normally
used to seeing movies and he just messes
with them he makes chapters he flips
time zones people are commenting we
circle back where are we
so he does a lot of fun with with
structure because he understands what
he's playing with
you know
if people are interested in
jim jarmisch also creates movies that
are um
not the normal structure that we're used
to
um you know
but these are people who are really
doing
like
really cool experimental stuff but they
also understand movies
all kinds of movies and that's why
they're so successful breaking the rules
and subverting you know the conventions
so yeah so that old adage before you can
break the rules you have to know the
rules that's right that's right i
believe that
why is it important for writers to start
their story slowly and take their time
with introducing the characters
that's such a great that's such a great
question because
um we need that time to be introduced to
your characters
to create that empathy that we talked
about like
that's where you have the luxury
of having a little bit of time up front
to establish who they are
what they want
why they want it and to allow us to kind
of be introduced to their world
and really get connected to them so that
we're willing to follow them on the
journey
and you know um that takes pages
you know i'm not saying you should spend
like you know 20 pages introducing your
main character you shouldn't if you're
writing a feature for sure you know you
you pretty much do need to kind of get
to that inciting incident or that call
to adventure pretty quickly
but we need but look at wally you know
like that little character we just like
follow him around in his little world
doing his little thing and we learned so
much about him
and we basically fall in love with him
and we will follow that little robot
dude anywhere right and so but we also
get introduced to the world and the
stakes in the world and that there's
nothing really living in the world you
know and so um i think that's just a
really beautiful example of visually um
starting slow and
letting us connect to our character and
his world
and in the queen's gambit i know we we
took some time yes and the back story
wasn't always clear why she was in the
orphanage right and different things are
revealed later and it really keeps you
but why is she reacting this way oh and
then finally you see
the conversation
[Music]
i don't want to give away too much but
yeah just little snippets and it takes
time yeah it takes time and it also
you know as the writer
when you're writing you're starting to
write whether it's your pilot or your
future it's like you know your job is to
create questions not give answers
your your job is to create questions
like why is she like you said why is she
doing that
what's going on here so that the
audience is like
we're just moving closer and closer
because we want to know
why is she acting that way
will she be able to be like a chess
champion will she beat that that guy or
whatever you know it's like all these
questions
that you set up in the story is really
what holds us to the story and so you
know in setting up your character you
don't want to just tell us a bunch of
stuff about the character you know maybe
we see them do something and we go
that's weird why are they doing that
and we keep wondering that until later
we get the answer to that question as as
we start to fully understand kind of who
this person is and why they are the way
they are you know um so yeah
you're kind of like putting up you're
creating trails you know breadcrumbs and
you're leaving blank spots
um and one thing
one thing to think about too as a writer
which i think is really important is to
create ellipses in your story where
there's gaps where
maybe we you know if you have a section
of your script and it just feels like
here we go every you know then she
drives here and then she gets out then
you know it's like do a time cut like
what's the next scene that moves the
story forward like let us the audience
actively engage with the narrative to
figure it out because the more we're
doing that
the more interested we are in your story
so you know leave gaps ask questions
um and you know um yeah take that time
at the beginning for sure why is it
important for the main character to have
a transformation
oh
the main character
okay so
let's be honest most main characters do
have transformations in most hollywood
movies right there's some growth
there are main characters who don't
transform
forrest gump
does he change no he just like he just
stays the same through the whole movie
the early james bond movies james bond
doesn't really change he's just getting
the chicks and you know bringing down
the bad guy
right so
the thing to remember is
it's not necessarily that your main
character has to transform it's that you
need transformation in your story
because that is actually what's
important so um
so if you have a main character who
doesn't change
and they kind of move through the story
like this what happens is
they change everyone around them
like forrest gump changes everyone
around him but he's still force gump
right
you know james bond it's been
interesting to watch him sort of evolve
you know with the daniel craig version
because
9 11 like suddenly james bond became
like this wounded hero where he was
always just the suave martini girls you
know blasting off into space roger moore
he was the one that i grew up with roger
moore
um but it's been interesting to watch
his character evolve you know and become
more of a character that has a tiny bit
more of an emotional
range you know in the in the stories um
but yeah it you know transformation in a
story is a key element and whether it
comes through your main character
or your main character changing um
everyone else it doesn't matter it's
just that transformation is actually the
purpose of a story
it's actually the purpose of the story
because the reason we tell stories is to
actually understand ourselves better
and that insight is a transformation for
us
okay so
however you package your transformation
in your story have at it you know it's
up to you
but the reason we watch stories is to be
transformed
so if someone were looking to write a
forrest gump type scenario
maybe leave it for a few scripts down
the line because that was very specific
how all that was done and there's many
timelines
yeah that was a very complex script for
sure
um
yeah it's easier to write a story where
the main character changes right because
it's just clearer or whatever but if you
really have a character
who doesn't change who kind of takes us
through the story but really the point
of the movie is how this person
changes the world around him or her or
them
then you know for sure write that story
it's just it's just ha think about how
why is that person um why is that person
the catalyst to change all these other
people you know and how can they change
the world around them
you know yeah
great great
yeah i'm not sure with queen's gambit
i would say she she had a shift she did
okay i mean it's not a huge one right
right it's like
did she really change you know
but i felt like she did because i felt
like um
i don't know i'm not an expert on the
queen's gambit um but i
i like i love what scott frank did
because
um she's she's impenetrable in a way
like she really is impenetrable you know
um
and the actress is is sort of has that
face that's impenetrable you know
um and at the same time i felt like
i got close to her
i got close to her like the mask was
pierced by the end of the of this of the
show
you know um even though she didn't have
this huge you know transformation like a
lot of main characters do
um but i think she i think she did she
did she did grow and we pierced her mask
we did but she did feel like an engine
driving sort of because even the camera
movement it would follow her up
yes you saw she was driving the shots
yes she brings us into the world and the
scenes um and she is very sort of like
mask-like you know and she doesn't give
a lot of emotion and the character isn't
written that way and um
but i i did feel that i was taken on a
transformative journey for sure
you know and that's that's a that's a
true that's a tribute to scott frank's
abilities as a writer to be able to
coordinate this character
who um
seems at once kind of like opaque
and yet at the same time creates this
feeling of transformation by the end of
that show we're just like
i've had this journey she has taken me
on this journey you know with her
which was really great
how much easier is it for the writer if
they know from the beginning what the
character wants
million times easier
it's a million times easier if you kind
of know what the character wants
but there's always a starting point you
think you know what they want at the
beginning and you start writing with
that and then it can shift
you know and so um
i think it's the most important thing
like i said earlier you know
when i do consultations with people it's
the singular most popular problem in the
script is what do they want
how are they trying to get it you know
what are they doing to try to get it
how does that make them face something
in themselves and how do they grow and
do they finally get this thing or do
they get it in a way that they didn't
expect
so um i think i think i always try to
start out like what do they want because
i've learned over the years like i need
to know what that is because that's the
engine that drives their actions through
the story
and when i don't know that and i start
to write i'm just kind of like just
driving over here i'm driving over here
i don't know you know it just it ends up
being i throw out a lot of pages
so i think you can start like what is
their emotional need you know do they
want love do they want revenge
what is it that's driving them and then
what's the specific thing they think is
gonna get is gonna satisfy that need and
how do they pursue that
and um you may start with that and you
may shift it you know as you start to
write you realize oh that's not what
they want at all they want this other
thing so then you're gonna have to go
back
and kind of you know reverse engineer
what you did but it's okay that's the
process you know and a lot of times
characters um goals shift in the movie
you know like in get out which is a
great movie you know chris he wants to
go and press her family in the middle of
the in the middle of the movie his goal
shifts to like i need to get out of here
they're going to hijack my body and my
brain
right so so that that shifts in in the
story but but that's good that's okay
but he still has a goal
throughout that drives him
and you've said before that sometimes
when you sit down to write that your
character sometimes starts to tell you
what they want in a sense yeah
i just had an experience with this barf
thing that i did this thing that i just
vomited out like i'm just gonna write
right right and i was just like i kind
of had the plot in my head because again
this side the left side is so dominant
in my brain and i was just like okay
this is when this happens and then
suddenly she's in the middle of the
scene and like
there's a flashback where somebody's
she's curled up in a ball in the
bathroom and someone's throwing movie
magazines at her from the 1940s and i
was like
then i went back into the scene i'm like
well that just happened i
i don't know what happened to her but
something happened to her and then i
kept writing and then again when i went
back that was where all that whole
backstory is what the whole thing is
really about
why she's doing what she's doing
what she's gonna have to face you know
in the story
but that was never in my brain that that
would ever happen i would that there
were that flashback was just going to
pop up in the middle of my writing
um but it was great they she started
talking to me she started telling me
stuff that happened to her and i was
like okay
what if we can't figure out what the
character wants
oh wow yeah
what if you can't figure out what the
character wants
again a very common issue right
some strategies that you might do to try
to figure out what the character wants
um is to figure out um what they're
afraid of
what are they afraid of like what are
they scared of
and what do they want that's in contrast
to that you know does the could their
want come from wanting the opposite of
that fear
do you know what i mean if they're
afraid let's say they were had a
traumatic past or traumatic childhood
you know um could
they really want just the perfect family
you know could you start from fear and
generate a want as the opposite of that
um that's one way to kind of try to
generate some ideas about you know what
your character could want um one thing
that i often do with my clients and my
students is
i have them write a monologue
and
monologues in movies are
we're not supposed to write monologues
it's one of the rules but you know what
this exercise is actually really helpful
and what i ask them to do is to sit down
and imagine their character is in a room
with someone else in the movie that they
trust another character that they trust
and that other character says
what do you want
and this character tells that other
character what they want
and i
i ask the writers to use all their five
senses to describe this dream that they
have
and just to allow that character to talk
to the writer and describe what they
want with no preconceptions
and usually out of and i say write for
five minutes and don't stop so just
stream of consciousness i want this and
you know
somewhere in there is the is a kernel of
something that they can actually grab
onto
and hold on to so again giving an
invitation to your character to speak to
you about what they want
so if they don't know what the character
wants it doesn't necessarily mean they
need to abandon it that that character
is not really connecting with them no
okay no it's just that they don't know
yet
they have to listen
they aren't listening they're trying to
like put things on the character you
know if you step into the character and
let them talk
they will tell you things you know so
let them tell someone else in the movie
what they want
what are the ways a writer can create
stakes for their character
oh great question
so obviously stakes are really important
for characters because they create
suspense and tension around
the goal right so if they don't achieve
what they want to achieve something
terrible will happen they will lose
something
there linda seeger wrote this really
great book called how to make a good
script great it's not just for rewriting
you can use it to write a first draft
but she actually has a really great
chapter on stakes and what she came up
with is a list
of what is a list of stakes for any
human being and i i'm going to try to
remember off the top of my head but it's
like survival
love and belonging
security
security
um
uh the aesthetic which is a sense of
order
control um
self-actualization which is
self-expression so
the loss of any one of these things on
this list is devastating for a human
right
survival physical survival oh my god i'm
dead right love and belonging if we
don't have love and belonging
we're basically dead safety and security
we also need that if we don't have it
it's going to be bad right so all of
these stakes
one way to think about that is to look
at her list and i think it's online
somewhere if people want to check it out
um
but but look at that list and and think
about it in relation to my character's
goal if they don't like for example if i
don't make that person love me what will
i lose
love you know which ones on this list am
i gonna lose
and if you if you watch a lot of movies
and you think about this and you think
about the stakes that the writers have
set up for their main characters usually
it's everything on that list except for
one or two things they stack the stakes
for the main character so it's just not
love and belonging it's also safety and
security it's also self-actualization
it's actually you know um maybe later in
the movie something happens where now
it's survival i'm gonna die they pile on
the stakes and every good writer has to
be able to articulate
what the character is gonna lose if they
don't get what they want
again everything is connected to the
character and their goal
so if they don't get this thing
what will be lost
and the more you can stack those stakes
for your character the more
tension and suspense
um and kind of like we're just gonna be
like oh no they're not gonna if they
it's just gonna create in the audience
this
like connection and fear that they're
not gonna get what they want which is
what you want in the story
so just like the is that maslow's
hierarchy of needs yeah so i think at
the at the very bottom of it or
area i'm trying to think if i flipped it
so self-actualization i think is is the
last one yes
and then survive safety
and survival yeah okay and linda seeger
created the screenwriting version of
that list nice yeah okay and so if you
took like a jenga piece if we take one
of those away
then that that's gonna raise the stakes
no matter what it is
yeah okay yeah interesting yeah like
like you know um i was thinking about um
the movie coco you know the pixar movie
coco about the little kid miguel who has
to go to the land of the dead so he can
find his ancestor so that he can become
a musician which is what he's meant to
be right
and i went through um linda seeger's
list of all those stakes you know um and
he had everything except one
and it that's just good writing you know
he's not just gonna physically
possibly die he's gonna lose his family
he's gonna lose safety he's gonna um not
be who he's meant to be like everything
like this kid it's gonna it's gonna be
horrible
if he doesn't achieve his goal
and so again the writer has to be able
to understand and articulate you know
what's at stake for the character